it's the start of the biggest travel
window across the u.s for millions
christmas and new year holidays start
here and the threat from the omicron
variant hasn't kept people home but has
given them some worry i'm very concerned
about it because
the flights are full
inside the lobby is full
on the planes of full covert testing
lines are back too some people waiting
hours to get checked out my brother woke
up not feeling good with a fever and i
got a text during lunch saying that he
got it so
this place is always open
the variant is now in at least 40 states
places like connecticut and michigan are
seeing significant surges in hospital
admissions new york state has seen its
highest single day reporting of
infections since the pandemic began 21
000 new cases on friday a record experts
are predicting will soon be broken
omicron is here
it's going to start to spread much more
rapidly at the beginning of the year
and the only real protection
is to get your shots
meanwhile a federal court has reinstated
the biden administration's vaccine
mandate for big companies that means
workers at companies with more than 100
employees will have to either be
vaccinated or undergo weekly testing an
appeals court saying the government must
be allowed to respond to covert dangers
as they evolve some republican states
oppose the idea it's a measure which is
now almost certainly going to end up
being argued at the supreme court for
the white house though it's a small
victory in a sea of much bleaker news
alan fisher al jazeera washington